bonsoir stanislas godon merci d'être
avec nous en direction est et france on
n'a pas eu la chance malheureusement
devoir
un petit peu la teneur de ce que nous
disait emmanuel macron ce matin dans le
figaro et la teneur de sa visite à
montpellier mais en gros le président
tente de défendre son bilan sur la
sécurité
vous avez évidemment lui en ces colonnes
du figaro vous avez suivi cette visite
est ce que vous vous avez été convaincu
ben tout d'abord on a un peu
l'impression quand même qu'il ya une
campagne électorale qui est en train de
s'annoncer où il ya un affichage de
communication au montant de renouer
aussi le dialogue avec je dirais
l'univers de la police nationale parce
que il ya eu des déclarations par le
passé qui ont profondément heurté la
maison police et les collègues sur le
terrain mais absolument pas apprécié le
contrôle au faciès des violences
policières qui qui avait jeté un peu
l'opprobre sur le travail de mes
collègues au quotidien alors là et je
dirais cet art conquête pas républicaine
mais la reconquête dans l'univers de la
police avec un bilan avec des annonces
aussi sur ce qui devrait être fait bon
nous on attend surtout des actes parce
que vous savez que les policiers on a eu
beaucoup de déclarations politiques
on nous a un jour adoubée on nous a
demandés on nous a dit féliciter parce
qu'on avait tenu à bout de bras la
république et on avait préservé la
république dans le cadre des
manifestations de gilet jaune dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
et puis chaque fois qu'il ya eu des
événements un peu compliqué eh ben tout
de suite on a jeté un peu les policiers
en pâture et puis c'était la présomption
de culpabilité
donc non il faut là qui est un soutien
de tous les instants et qui plus est
aujourd'hui ans et maman très compliqué
pour les policiers je rappelle que tous
les jours nous avons des actes de
violences urbaines à l'encontre des
policiers
tous les jours c'est du cocktail molotov
ces deux gènes mortiers d'artifice et
des insultes
c'est ça la réalité du policier au
quotidien aujourd'hui et je crois que
dans le débat qu'il ya sur la sécurité
on ne pourra pas dissocier à la fois
l'univers de la police l'univers de
sécurité et lui
vert de la justice parce que les deux
doivent marcher sur leurs deux jambes
stanislas gonds clairement vous dites
voilà on s'est sentis par moments
totalement abandonné 1
c'est en substance l'idée que vous vous
véhiculez il ya eu deux tendances mandat
de d'emmanuel macron il ya eu l'époque
castaner on sait qui a été assez
compliqué pour vous les policiers est ce
que les choses se sont un petit peu
apaisées avec le nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur qui n'est plus si nouveau
d'ailleurs gérald darmanin
alors il est clair que monsieur darmanin
est venu avec d'abord une casquette de
ministre de décompter de l'action
publique et qu'il a donné un grand coup
de pouce d'un point de vue du budget de
la police nationale alors c'est vrai que
nous allons profiter cette année d'un
plan de relance avec des dispositions
intéressantes au niveau de l'immobilier
au niveau des caméras mobiles même si ce
n'est pas encore suffisant au niveau des
du remplacement des véhicules donc ça ce
sont des dispositions qui sont
intéressantes et qui vont très
rapidement se mesurer sur le terrain
maintenant il y à un autre volet
plusieurs volets d'ailleurs qui sont par
exemple la formation continue des agents
nous demandons à ce qu'il y ait un
nombre d'heures dédié pour les foncières
de police puisqu'il pour qu'ils puissent
s'entraîner dans tous les domaines
d'ailleurs que ce soit les gestes et
professionnel que ce soit en matière
judiciaire que ce soit en gestes ans
notamment en contact avec le public
puisque souvent nous a reproché d'avoir
une certaine défaillance même s'il ya eu
un audit qui a déclaré quand même plus
de 400 commissariat avec de l'accueil du
public avec des opinions plutôt
favorable et puis enfin il faudra à
tordre le cou un jour à cette espèce de
petite musique qui dit qu' il y as
divorce entre la police et la population
je ne crois pas les sondages le montrent
plus de 70% des descendit montres ont
une opinion favorable et la police
secours à 91%
par contre on peut pas en dire
on peut pas dire la même chose par
rapport à la justice que je rappelle que
moins d'un français sur deux fait
confiance en la justice
clairement dit milla policiers de plus
sur le terrain plus de bleu en libye
mais cros 1 d'ici à 2022 c'est l'une
l'un des débuts de solutions pour vous
c'est pas un scoop puisque c'était une
annonce qui avait été fait dès l'arrivée
au pouvoir du président de la république
il avait annoncé la création et ça c'est
important de le dire la création de dix
mille postes en police et en gendarmerie
pour l'instant nous n'en sommes pas au
bout des dix mille notamment des 7500
sur le périmètre comme police nationale
mais attention nous nous disons mettre
des effectifs c'est important certes
puisqu'il faut rattraper la perte de
personnel de police
quel que soit d'ailleurs les corps qui a
été effectuée pendant la révision
générale des politiques publiques
par contre attention il faut également
repenser les missions du policier le
recentrer sur son coeur de métier
supprimer toutes les tâches indues qui
nous empoisonnent le quotidien
simplifier les procédures pénales pour
que nos collègues qui travaillent en
investigation et bien il puisse enfin
faire du travail réel denquête et pas
faire de la paperasse qui les
empoisonnent au quotidien et puis sur
pardonnez-moi ceni 16 go dont les
laitages comme ça vous pensez par
exemple au contrôle
suu kyi sont liés aux restrictions
sanitaires on imagine que ça vous prend
beaucoup de temps ça ça nous prend
beaucoup de temps mais c'est vrai qu'on
préférait courir après les délinquants
maintenant il ya une crise sanitaire
qu'il faut absolument combattre et tous
les acteurs sont importants je crois que
il faut pas occulter le fait que malgré
tous les contrôles ont eu un effet même
si on n'est pas dans le tout répressif
et que mes collections terrain où fo ont
fait preuve de beaucoup de discernement
quand je parle des tâches ardues c'est
par exemple l'écart préfecture s'est par
exemple les transfèrements de détenus
alors que normalement ça devrait être
rebasculer à la pénitentiaire
je pense notamment à tout ce qui a trait
aux procurations électorale et le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé qu'il
y aurait des dispositions qui serait
prise parce que nous arrivons dans un
calendrier très important avec des
régionales et départementales et les
présidentielles en 2022 donc ça ça fait
partie des choses qu'il faut remettre au
quotidien tout comme d'ailleurs la loi
sécurité globale et on espère que le
transfert notamment des ivresses
publiques et manifestes à la police
municipale se fera intégralement
arménienne la con qui fait aussi de la
lutte contre les trafics de drogue
une priorité c'est la mère des batailles
dans dit il vous partagez le même
constat alors bien sûr parce que nous ça
fait des années qu'on dit le trafic des
stupéfiants
il génère d'abord beaucoup d'argent plus
pratiquement 2 3 milliards d'euros
il génère une économie parallèle il crée
en fait de la délinquance au quotidien
et on voit bien dans les réactions dans
certains quartiers que la police elle
gêne et que du coup on tente d'attaquer
la police parce que il faut pas qu'elle
fasse son travail sereinement
oui c'est un combat de tous les instants
mais attention on ne nous trompons pas
il faut à la fois s'attaquer au point tu
dis mais surtout s'attaquer aux réseaux
aux grands réseaux de trafic de
stupéfiants et il faut aussi que
derrière la justice fasse son travail
et lorsque nous amenons
des procédures qui sont parfois très
compliqué très longue dans le temps eh
bien il faut aussi que derrière il est
une réponse pénale qui soit adaptée
extrêmement ferme pour pas qu'on se
retrouve avec les mêmes personnes qui
commettent les mêmes méfaits
quand ils reviennent notamment dans leur
quartier et les mesures d'éloignement
ont tous leur sens d'ailleurs ça sera ma
dernière question à ce qu'aujourd'hui
clairement la police a les moyens de
démontrer ses trafics parce que vous
nous dites voilà on sent qu'on gêne on
est souvent attaqué sur le terrain le
jour où la guerre sera lancée vraiment à
ces trafics de drogue est ce que il n'ya
pas une crainte d'un embrasement des
quartiers difficiles mais l'embrassement
il est panier ça mon trafic de
stupéfiants il est lié surtout à
l'infinity aujourd'hui n'ont plus peur
d'attaqués de tendre des guet-apens aux
policiers qui arrivent sur le terrain
même quand d'ailleurs ils font des
patrouilles tout ça mais qui sont pas
dans un acte de répression et d'ailleurs
pour aller plus loin il attaque même les
banquiers lorsqu'ils portent secours aux
personnes
donc vous voyez à quel point on en est
arrivé à une banalisation de la de
l'ultra violence et puis surtout un
rejet de l'autorité des tas de tout ce
qui porte un uniforme et je crois que là
aussi il faudra qu'il y ait un travail
vous avez demain on va manifester devant
les tribunaux judiciaires parce que nous
pensons que le verdict de suite au
procès de viry-châtillon bas est un
exemple et une dénonçons depuis des
années la justice ne rend pas la justice
à la hauteur des préjudices subis à la
hauteur je dirais des infractions
commises c'est bien pour ça que nous
demandons dans le cadre du bota sécurité
la création d'un observatoire de la
réponse pénale pour qu'on fasse de la
transparence sur les infractions
commises les peines encourues les peines
prononcées et surtout des peines
exécutées
parce qu'aujourd'hui en france on parle
pas beaucoup on fait beaucoup de gestion
paul et de population carcérale mais on
ne parle pas beaucoup
je dirais des individus qui sont
interpellés et la manière dont
que dont ils réparent les dommages
qu'ils ont causés à la société merci
beaucoup stanislas godon d'avoir été
avec nous et je vous le dis